all right i teased this earlier let's uh
let's get right to it there is now um a
statement that has been made by
republican congresswoman liz chaney
who's on the house select committee
committee investigating the january six
riots
she says they have first-hand testimony
that ivanka trump among others but
ivanka trump the president the former
president's own daughter
asked donald trump please do something
to stop these riots on january 6th and
of course he did not and this continues
to kind of
flesh out the picture that we are
building
uh about
exactly who did what and when on that
day what were the goals what were the
intentions what were the priorities of
different people and this is just
unbelievable liz cheney we have
firsthand testimony ivanka asked trump
to stop the january 6th capital riot
uh the house select committee
investigating the riots has received
first-hand testimony that trump's
daughter ivanka twice asked him to
intervene trump was watching the riot
unfold on tv while sitting in the dining
room next to the oval office at the time
let's go right into the clips this is
liz cheney appearing yesterday with
george stephanopoulos on abc
it is uh
it's everything we imagined guys
is his failure to make that statement
criminal negligence
you know i i think that that there are a
number of as the chairman said
potential criminal statutes at issue
here
but i think that that there's absolutely
no question that it was a dereliction of
duty
and and i think one of the things the
committee needs to look at as we're
looking at a legislative purpose is
whether we need enhanced penalties for
that kind of dereliction of duty now i
want to be real there's a reason she's
saying this and this goes back to what
we talked about uh last week
officially
a congressional committee's main purpose
can't be to figure out if someone
committed a crime
and trump has tried to stop the
investigation by saying they're
primarily just looking to see if i
committed a crime
liz cheney is saying
exactly what she has to say now whether
it's true or maybe they are primarily
looking at whether trump committed a
crime but at least what has to be said
is
our interest is
as lawmakers are there laws we need to
pass to prevent this from happening
again
if we happen to come across crimes that
were committed in so figuring that out
then we can refer those crimes there's a
if you saw that segment last week you
understand the legal relevance of that
but let's continue
uh but but i think it's also important
for the american people to understand
how dangerous donald trump was
we know as he was sitting there in the
dining room next to the oval office uh
members of his staff were pleading with
him to go on television to tell people
to stop we know leader mccarthy
was pleading with him to do that we know
members of his family we know his
daughter we have first-hand testimony
that his daughter ivanka went in at
least twice
to ask him to please stop this violence
any man who would not do so any man who
would provoke a violent assault on the
capitol to stop the counting of
electoral votes any man who would watch
television as police officers were being
beaten
as as his supporters were invading the
capital of the united states is clearly
unfit for future office
clearly can never be anywhere near the
oval office uh ever again so this was a
very interesting and wide-ranging
interview let's go to another segment
here where the topic is again at any
point trump could have put a stop to
this any point and he did not we're
joined now by the vice chair of the
committee congresswoman liz cheney
councilman cheney thank you for joining
us again this morning happy new year
to you you know you were alarmed by this
from the very start from the moment so
the first moments on january 6 when this
started to unfold you've cut a lonely
path in your party have you been
surprised by anything you've found over
the last year
well i've certainly been surprised by
many things i think that in the piece
that you played by john carl just a few
moments ago
he touched on the fact
that that we know now we are learning
much more about what former president
trump was doing while the violent
assault was underway the committee has
first-hand testimony now that he was
sitting in the dining room next to the
oval office watching the attack on
television
as as the assault on the capitol
occurred
we know
as you you know well
that the briefing room at the white
house is just a mere few steps from the
oval office the president could have at
any moment walked those very few steps
into the briefing room gone on live
television and told his supporters who
were assaulting the capitol to stop he
could have told him to stand down he
could have told him to go home
and he failed to do so it's hard to
imagine a more significant and more
serious dereliction of duty it's funny
to say he failed because it does i mean
he didn't he chose not to do it failed
almost suggests he wasn't able but he
chose not to
and uh two-thirds of the country and a
lot of the world asked the exact same
questions liz cheney is asking here
which is why why not do it
and um one last segment here and again
this is this is liz cheney
she's she's
all power to her she's saying we have to
be loyal here to the country not to
trump and this isn't good for the
republican party liz cheney is a
right-wing republican
with whom i disagree on just about
everything she voted with trump
something like 93 percent of the time
but on this particular issue she is
correct you're about as stalwart
republican as i've ever met you come
from a long line of republicans as well
of course your father served
in the white house your mother served
in administrations as well how do you
explain given your belief your views and
your background
why a majority of republicans today
would re-elect donald trump look i i
think that um we're in a situation as a
nation where i certainly have very
strong disagreements with policies of
the biden administration i think that
the policies that vice president
president biden has adopted are the
wrong ones for this country i think we
need conservative principled leadership
but the republican party has to make a
choice we can either be loyal to our
constitution or loyal to donald trump
but we cannot be both and the nation
needs a republican party that is based
on substance and values and principles
uh and and we've got to get back to that
if we want to get this nation back on
track but fundamentally at the end of
the day we can't be a party that's based
on lies we've got to be based on a
foundation of truth
and fidelity to the rule of law so
listen she she's saying all the right
things and i applaud her for it i do
this is still not someone who's going to
be one of our political allies but would
we be better off if more republicans
saw trumpism and their party and country
really as three different things and
that you can be on the side of one or
two of those without having to stand by
donald trump of course we would be
better off of course we would be better
off so there is liz cheney ivanka ivanka
firsthand testimony that ivanka multiple
times tried to get trump to do something
uh and trump didn't until hours later
said in a video it's time to go home we
love you
we know why you're here it was stolen
but it's time to go home a completely
pathetic pathetic almost non-reaction to
the horrors of january 6th and trump
will be doing a press conference on
thursday january 6th the anniversary of
the riots making some kind of statement
we don't know what that will be but we
can be almost certain it's going to be
completely whacked out
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 thousand five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off and free shipping
when you go to four sigmatic dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video